i
[Música]
el mundo superó los 100 millones de
casos de kobe 19 mientras los países
luchan contra la pandemia con escasez de
vacunas entretanto continúan los
desacuerdos entre la unión europea y
astrazéneca por el retraso en la entrega
de las inyecciones tenemos información
desde bruselas
perú y a ecuador militarizan sus
fronteras para detener la migración
venezolana con camiones blindados y
cientos de militares en los pasos
irregulares en medio de la pandemia los
venezolanos intentan buscar una vida
digna
en su primera semana en el poder el
presidente de estadounidense joe biden
firmó una serie de órdenes ejecutivas
para deshacer el legado de donald trump
uno de los temas clave ha sido la lucha
contra el cambio climático analizamos en
esta visión
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france24 sierra blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos a este informativo con la
atención entre la unión europea y
astrazéneca por la lenta distribución de
la vacuna la unión europea y la empresa
se encuentran en una disputa desde el
viernes cuando astrazéneca anunció un
recorte en el suministro de su vacuna
contra el kobe 19 debido a problemas de
producción en una de sus plantas la
comisión europea le exigió este
miércoles que encuentra soluciones para
cumplir con sus compromisos adquiridos
desde bruselas esther herrera con los
detalles
el estira y afloja entre la unión
europea y la farmacéutica astrazéneca se
mantiene después de que la farmacéutica
haya anunciado que sólo cumplirá con una
cuarta parte de las dosis comprometidas
con la unión europea después del de una
reunión de más de tres horas entre la
farmacéutica y la comisión europea las
razones esgrimidas por la compañía
siguen sin convencer a bruselas así lo
ha asegurado la comisión de sanidad
desde la adquirí aquí des que ha dicho
que las explicaciones dadas por la
compañía no son suficientemente claras
ni tampoco han explicado aún cómo
piensan cumplir con el calendario de
distribución y de producción de las
vacunas la comisión europea exige que la
farmacéutica cumpla con sus compromisos
y que pueda utilizar todas las plantas
de producción posibles no sólo la de
bélgica y también la de alemania sino
también las dos plantas de producción
que hay en el reino unido aún así la
reunión ha sido muchísimo más fluida
después de casi varios días de
prácticamente tierra
entre hasta zénica y la unión europea
pero de momento aún no hay una solución
que satisfaga a la unión europea además
queda decir que la agencia europea del
medicamento se reúne el próximo viernes
para ver si aprueba la vacuna de
astrazéneca aún sin saber con cuántas
dosis va a poder contar la unión europea
y es que chile aprobó hoy el uso de
emergencia de la vacuna contra el coi 19
desarrollada por la farmacéutica
astrazéneca para ser aplicada en mayores
de 18 años las autoridades confirmaron
que en marzo empezarían a llegar las 4
millones de dosis compradas directamente
y otras 2.600.000 adquiridas a través
del programa kóvacs de la o ms hasta el
momento más de 56 mil personas han sido
inmunizadas en chile el gobierno espera
vacunar a 12 de los 19 millones de
habitantes durante el primer semestre
del presente año con esto tenemos
alrededor de contando las autorizaciones
la primera actualización los países
fueron 10 millones sino que fueron estos
10 millones y esta solicitaron 6
millones de dosis por lo tanto
tendríamos re 216 millones de dosis
autorizada en chile- camiones blindados
y cientos de militares en las fronteras
peruanas y ecuatorianas esa última
estrategia de los gobiernos para frenar
la migración sobre todo de personas
venezolanas que en medio de la pandemia
intentan buscar una vida digna caminando
durante semanas y medicinas y con un
alto riesgo de contagio marina sardiña
huyen del virus del hambre había a
través de las trochas y en las bermas de
las carreteras el cierre de las
fronteras por la pandemia de kobe 19 en
los países andinos no cesa el empeño de
miles de emigrantes venezolanos que
buscan una vida digna para ellos y sus
familias para nadie un secreto para
conseguir dinero en venezuela es muy
difícil
y pues nos tocó venir de mochileros ya
tenemos 21 chillando y por trocha
y bueno toca pasar un río camina monte
con mucho riesgo riesgo pasado hambre
también ha sido fuerte la cosa algunos
que otras personas nos ayudan otras nos
tratan mal nos ofenden nos insultan se
cuentan por miles los migrantes que cada
mes siguen caminando desde colombia
hacia perú y ecuador a través de
peligrosos pasos ilegales que las
autoridades de estos países no logran
controlar muchas veces gestionadas por
mafias los venezolanas se ven obligados
a mendigar para poder pagar entre los 5
y 10 dólares que les exigen las mafias
para cruzar las fronteras una valiosa
cantidad para los que no tienen nada a
la precaria situación de estas personas
que viajan durante semanas se suma la
cada vez mayor militarización de las
fronteras en estos países tanto ecuador
como perú desplegaron más de 50
vehículos del ejército y 1.200 soldados
para frenar el paso de los migrantes
tenemos un despliegue tanto del lado
peruano como del lado ecuatoriano
también es observado tropa ecuatoriana
de los dos lados de la frontera y creo
que eso muestra que tenemos estamos
haciendo un esfuerzo conjunto para
garantizar que cualquier paso de un lado
a otro sea por la vía legal
día correcto los países de américa
latina están sumidos en la lucha contra
la segunda ola de contagios por el virus
siendo las restricciones a la migración
una de las principales herramientas
argumentando que los migrantes suponen
una amenaza sanitaria por el coronavirus
el presidente de eeuu joe biden
suspendió las perforaciones de
hidrocarburos en terreno federal es la
decisión no afectará a los contratos ya
existentes eeuu se comprometió además a
proteger el 30 por ciento de las tierras
y aguas federales para el año 2030 el
nuevo gobierno busca convertir el cambio
climático en una prioridad de su
política exterior y la seguridad
nacional
se trata de llegar al momento de
enfrentar esta máxima amenaza que ahora
se nos presenta enfrentar el cambio
climático con mayor sentido de urgencia
en mi opinión ya hemos esperado
demasiado tiempo para afrontar esta
crisis climática que no podemos esperar
más lo vemos con nuestros ojos lo
sentimos no sabemos 10 horas de actual
renault bones además del cambio
climático como prioridad en su agenda de
gobierno la migración es otra de las
banderas de la campaña de biden ha
revertido además a través de órdenes
ejecutivas decenas de medidas de su
antecesor donald trump un juez federal
en texas bloqueó temporalmente la medida
de byd en que suspendía la deportación
de inmigrantes indocumentados
período de 100 días para hablar sobre
este tema quiero saludar en ese momento
a teodoro aguiluz director ejecutivo del
centro de recursos centroamericanos en
houston texas señor alí luz gracias por
estar aquí con nosotros en france 24 le
pregunto si con este bloqueo la orden
del presidente de bailén queda anulada
en texas y que prosiguen con las
deportaciones e inmediatamente
bueno definitivamente
no es muy buena noticia esto aunque ha
ocurrido en tiempos anteriores también
ocurrió con el caso de la implementación
de la ncaa que es el programa que le da
acceso a los jóvenes para poder obtener
un permiso de trabajo pero esto es
temporal y creemos que tienen suceder en
el estado muy conservador que
acordémonos pues es aquí donde el
senador ted cruz uno de los que se
envalentonaron para la situación de lo
que ocurrió en la toma del capitolio el
estado de texas ha sido un estado muy
conservador y ahorita en el tiempo del
trump ismo lógicamente este estado se
envalentonó más con las milicias
racistas y eso lógicamente
el hecho de que se suspenda la
deportación de las gentes de las
personas que no tienen ninguna
protección migratoria sí pero que se ha
bloqueado por parte de un fuerza tiene
un estado de texas que instancia legal
sigue y que pueden hacer las
organizaciones defensoras de migrantes
para detener estas deportaciones bueno
siempre ha habido una actividad de calle
siempre ha habido una actividad continua
y creemos de que en este momento ya hay
un equipo de abogados especialmente
especializados en el área de inmigración
que han estado trabajando y esto aunque
es temporal
está enviando un mensaje verdad de
oposición a las medidas que está
implementando está tratando de
implementar el presidente bayrén aunque
creemos que este son un lenguaje que se
está utilizando que cambia la temática
que había venido implementando la
administración anterior del presidente
trump
creemos de que esta situación aunque es
temporal pues envía un mensaje de
oposición a todas las las órdenes
ejecutivas que está emitiendo el
presidente a bailén pero creemos que la
lucha por parte de la señalización es
continua señor aguiluz gracias por su
tiempo y por estar aquí con nosotros en
france 24 que tenga usted una muy buena
noche ustedes también continúan con
nosotros hay mucho más para ver aquí
nuestro canal
[Música]